hillsdale college is unique in so many
ways and by my father's great vision and
luck I had the privilege of going there
at Hillsdale we believe strongly that
students have to come to college to
learn and they have to learn a number of
different things and they also have to
learn what they want to do if they don't
already know and sometimes what they
think they want to do changes as they go
along that path in college ninety-six
percent of our graduates six months are
either gainfully employed or they're
attending graduate school and continuing
their education in some way shape or
form we're very proud of those numbers
and the TDC companies and cleaves has
been very helpful in having us achieve
that number and achieve that goal in a
number of different ways first and
foremost they come to campus and they
talk to our students they interview our
students they give us opportunities to
have our students go to DDC companies
and do some job shadowing we have a
number of students that have internships
in the summertime and the real
internships a lot of times students will
get internships with bigger companies
and they'll be making copies or they
might be getting the coffee we know from
the feedback we get and the assessments
we get after interns come back from TDC
companies that we're doing real work
they're part of a real team they're
making real contributions they're
looking at the needs of whatever client
they might be working with that TDC is
helping and they're adding value to that
team and the service that TDC is
providing that client and that's
something that's just invaluable for our
students because it helps them
understand what they're going to do
after they graduate and it helps them
make a better decision and hopefully
maybe in some cases lead to full-time
employment did Hillsdale College teach
me stuff that becomes important in what
I do day-to-day over the last 25 years
i'd say directly no but more importantly
they gave me a greater gift they taught
me how to learn so that's why i love
Hillsdale College